[Musica]
tutti ci dicono di essere se stessi di
abbracciare ciò che ci rende diverso ma
come possiamo essere noi stessi quando
le persone sono i primi a giudicare le
stesse differenze appena esprimiamo la
nostra personalità come facciamo essere
noi stessi quando veniamo giudicati e
presi in giro per quello che è diverso
io sono già da zang e utilizzato la mia
diversità nel cesr cambiare il panorama
del food in italia e in europa
i miei genitori sono trasferiti in
italia dalla cina negli anni 90 e quando
sono nata e cresciuta in un piccolo
comune del nord italia cremona per me il
mondo era molto semplice la mia famiglia
cinese parlavo cinese e quando sono
andata finalmente a scuola mi si è
aperto un mondo nuovo una lingua nuova
d'italiano
mi ricordo ancora che era il 2002 in una
scuola di un comune piccolo italiano ai
tempi non si parlava di auto fiducia di
autostima di forma mentis se nascevi una
famiglia che era vantaggiato
allora viene premiato per questo serve
genitori che erano insegnanti venini
considerato più intelligente o più
dotato e nel tempo i vantaggi si
accumulavano invece volevo soltanto
essere considerata determinata e stare
alla pari con loro mi ricordo anche
ancora che c'erano queste giornate di
lettura dove bisognava imparare a
leggere i mesi dell'anno a scuola quando
fumo e turno un insegnante mi chiamò e
mi alzai e decisa iniziai a leggere
gennaio febbraio marzo inizia avere un
pochino più i dubbi su aprile
iniziai e ancora avere più difficoltà su
maggio e quando era il turno di giugno
mi bloccai completamente
golasecca bocca paralizzata
non riuscivo più a connettere il mio
cervello che scavava all'interno della
memoria per per ricordarsi quella parola
lì
volevo veramente sotterrarli lo sguardo
ai bambini che iniziano a ridere perché
non ero in grado di leggerli italiano in
quel momento sono tornata a casa il
giorno dopo ti sfida sul letto ripetevo
ogni singolo mese ogni singola parola
in ogni modo possibile e maledicevo la
mia stupidità
mi chiedevo perché sono nata cinese
perché non potevo lasciare italiana così
che non devono neanche imparare non
soltanto a leggere mesi ma anche a dirli
perché non conoscevo proprio il
significato di questi mesi
sappiamo che i miei genitori non
interessava così tanto che veramente
imparassi tutti i mesi dell'anno ma io
lo volevo lo volevo perché solo io
volevo riuscire non volevo che fosse
considerato ai miei compagni qualcuno
che non ce la faceva
ed è così che il giorno dopo sono
tornato a scuola e ho chiesto un
insegnante in voglio essere nuovo
interrogata e allora in un fiato
inizia a scandire ogni singolo mese e
riuscì a dirli tutti gennaio febbraio
marzo aprile maggio e giugno lo url hai
ancora prima che le lettere fossero
senso la lavagna e mi piace pensare oggi
che probabilmente un insegnante avrà
pensato brava già da brava questa
bambina cinese che ha avuto il coraggio
di dimostrare ai suoi compagni che ce la
fa
quel pò meglio sono tornata a casa con
un trofeo un trofeo invisibile perché
sono tornata a casa a testa alta ma
sapevo ancora che il percorso che dovevo
fare per raggiungere esser la paris era
ancora lunghissimo
l'apprendimento nel tempo è qualcosa che
poi iniziato a divertirmi molto perché
ho scoperto l'incoraggiante correlazione
tra quanto studi quanto file esercizi
quanto ti impegni con i risultati
ma ogni volta che portava a casa un voto
buono esultavo i giovani genitori che
bello finalmente preso 10 e loro mi
dicevano sciatta
non importa ricordati questo lo fai per
te e non lo fai per noi in fondo in
fondo so che erano contenti della mia
competitività e so ancora di più che
c'era dentro una fiamma che arde va
dentro di me e loro sapevano come
tenerla accesa
io avevo due scelte essere e continuare
ad essere l'ultima arrivata in classic
non conosceva l'italiano oppure
finalmente dare il mio massimo per
veramente aver la stima è tutta la stima
dei miei compagni e degli insegnanti
questo è un piccolo episodio ne
raccontano anche un altro qualche mese
dopo sono tornato a scuola
stranamente nessuno voleva giocare più
con me anche la mia migliore amica non
mi rivolgeva la parola e dice una cosa è
successo perchè vuole giocare con me ho
scoperto poco dopo che in cina c'era un
epidemia un'epidemia che andava a far
ammalare tutti gli animali e quindi
essendo in cina l'epidemia io sono
cinesi ero malato anch'io
ora pensando ci viene veramente da
ridere però ai tempi a sette anni
questo tipo di episodi ti colpisce molto
mi ricordo ancora i miei genitori che mi
spiegarono giada è una cosa molto
ingiusta e ingiusta ma sarà molto comune
la forma diversa ai nostri occhi a
mandorla ci rende vulnerabili e quindi
sarà qualcosa con cui dovrai convivere
sul per tutta la tua vita è molto vero e
non è soltanto un episodio che è
successo quando avevo sette anni ma
anche di recente solo ieri quando sono
arrivata qui atterrata taranto con gli
altri speaker all'uscita dell'aeroporto
hanno fermato solo me la sicurezza ha
fermato me perché avevo gli occhi a
mandorla perché lo diversa
e perché magari avevo qualcosa da
nascondere rispetto agli altri ma che
colpa ne ha il poliziotto della
sicurezza non è colpa sua
l'ho imparato che così deve essere il
suo mestiere ha imparato che se arriva
uno straniero probabilmente c'è più
probabilità che possa avere qualcosa non
in regola è difficile veramente sapere
come comportarsi in queste situazioni
perché tutti sembrano perfettamente al
loro posto ma tu non sai dove devi stare
più accadono situazioni così disagio e
più mi rendo conto che la strada che
avevo era sempre più lunga per trovare
veramente la mia voce
questo mi ha fatto capire un concetto
importante il fallimento il fallimento
prima ancora che sia veramente realtà è
una sensazione che sentiamo noi è una
sensazione che viene data dalla
vulnerabilità del fatto che non abbiamo
fiducia in noi stessi e che viene
alimentata ancora di più quando abbiamo
paura
in tutto il percorso che ho fatto
durante i cinque anni delle scuole
elementari
ho dato mio massimo e le insegnanti mi
hanno premiato per dove sono arrivata ma
non perché finalmente fosse alle pari
degli altri ma perché ho dovuto lavorare
il doppio
quando sono arrivato alle scuole medie
ho dovuto di nuovo confrontarmi con il
mondo reale un'insufficienza dopo
l'altra l'insegnante dopo un semestre
chiama me i miei genitori e dice vostra
figlia non ha la stoffa per rimanere qui
questo ma sconvolto mi ha sconvolto e
quello che sto cercando di fare lei
proper di insegnare dentro di me l'idea
di fallimento o ancora prima di aver
dimostrato che potevo farcela in tutti i
cinque anni delle scuole elementari ma
nuovo soltanto imparato a studiare a
dimostrare che potevo farcela ma
soprattutto imparato che non permetterò
a nessuno e soprattutto una persona a
mettere in dubbio quello che veramente
ho imparato e di sapere di me stessa di
quanto valevo io quel giorno sono stato
l'ufficio con lego ferito
più che mai
amy sonetto soltanto una cosa te la farò
vedere sto in tornata a casa e nei
prossimi anni proprio mi sono messa
capire a studiare cosa rendeva diverso
me da qualunque altro studente invece
che prendeva sempre voti più alti
ho iniziato a leggere netto studiare ed
è così che sono uscita dalle scuole
medie con il massimo dei voti le scuole
superiori con massimo di voti ad entrare
a fare economia delle scuole migliori in
tutto il mondo quello che veramente ho
imparato è che forse potrei tornare da
questo insegnante e dirle
guardi si sbagliava ma questo non
servirebbe né a me né a lei perché alla
fine è qualcosa che devi dimostrare a te
stesso perciò in tutto questo
gli studenti e le persone che
appartengono a minoranze hanno più sfida
davanti a loro devono accettare
continuamente nuove sfide nei genitori
sono di qui in italia non parlavano
italiano non conoscevo nessuno sono
partiti da zero e ogni giorno con una se
dopo l'altra ma questo richiede una
nozione richiede un livello di fiducia
incredibile ma soprattutto richiede
tanta energia
in tutto questo percorso
finalmente ho imparato che in realtà se
tu davvero ci metti tutta la forza
riesce ad arrivare dove vuoi quando in
super alle paure
la mia paura più grande è quella che
continuavo a ripetermi giorno dopo
giorno in tutti gli anni è ma sono
abbastanza non sono mai abbastanza non
ce la farò mai non arriverò mai loro
livello è solo quando finalmente sono
entrata al mondo lavorativo mi sono resa
conto che ce l'avevo fatta finalmente ho
scalato la montagna quando mi sono
trovata al 46esimo piano di un
grattacielo a londra lo stesso
grattacielo che quando ero piccola in un
bus turistico guardavo sbirciavo da
lontano e vedevo queste persone
camminare frettolosamente tutte ben
vestite entrare in questo in questo
grattacielo e l'ammiravo e oggi era il
mio turno ero una di loro
correvo velocemente scendeva dal bus
andavo in questo in questo ascensore
super silenzioso che importava al
46esimo piano e finalmente ero parte
dalla tribù
era una persona che finalmente aveva il
suo completo firmato ero a 22 anni la
più giovane retribuita bene quanto
nessun altro ha avuto la mia età e
soprattutto avevo colleghi coltì gentili
erano soprattutto uomini occidentali e
bianchi
avevo tutto quindi cos'è che non era a
posto niente tutto quello che ho avuto
nella vita lo ha colto dall'amore dei
miei genitori alla fiducia dei miei
insegnanti
ma la vera domanda qui e dobbiamo
accontentarci di quello che è e di
quello che c'è o vogliamo lavorare per
cambiarlo
una delle cose che io adoro una
recitazione che davvero ogni volta mi
ripeto è quella di gandhi sii il
cambiamento che vuoi vedere nel mondo ed
è così che tutto fu chiaro io non
contribuiva veramente nel rendere mondo
diverso facendo un lavoro che facevano
migliaia e migliaia di altre persone
anzi quello che veramente ho capito che
il mio scopo era diverso insieme con la
mia famiglia abbiamo iniziato un impresa
dove uniamo la mia di culturalità la
parte italiana da parte cinese
creiamo piatti pronti di cucina asiatica
che utilizziamo ricette autentiche del
della dell'asia ma utilizziamo gli
ingredienti italiani freschi e la
qualità del made in italy e questo
veramente risposto alle tutte le mie
domande
quando tu veramente fai qualcosa che
riesce a legare la cultura ciò che ti
senti la tua città da dove vieni tutto
più senso perciò io mi ritengo una
persona veramente normale una persona
normale che però avuto la fortuna e si è
trovato davanti a un viaggio
straordinario pieno di sfide fin da
piccola questo mi ha insegnato di avere
fiducia in me stessa e mi ha insegnato
anche a rispondere il sì sono bravo
abbastanza ma il motivo per cui oggi
condivido la mia storia è perché spero
di creare spazio ad altre storie ad
altre voci perché sono sicura che la
vera differenza è portare e riuscire a
poter veramente dimostrare di essere
qualcuno vi racconta la propria storia
unica con la voce autentica
per me questo essere alternativi ed è
significa soprattutto far coincidere chi
sei
con il posto da dove vieni e con quello
in cui andare
grazie